c'est quoi ton nom
star
[Applaudissements]
on a des questions sur le meurtre des
quatre jeunes femmes vous les aviez déjà
croisé vous me soupçonner c'est bien à
vous ça le briquet il a été retrouvé sur
la scène de crime on a un mobile et
votre alibi et léger
il voulait savoir si tu étais bien en
train de rejoindre la nuit dernière le
petit chauve là ils pensaient que
j'allais m'effondrer quand ils m'ont dit
que t'avais fleurs tertre
pourquoi vous ne diriez pas qui serait
dans le coup d'après vous j'ai rien à
voir là dedans j'ai parlé à pas mal de
monde et m'ont tous dit que vous étiez
un type sans histoire on essaie de le
coller 4 meur sur le dos en plein jour
bien sûr
je retournerais parole pour un truc que
j'ai pas fait
je tenais à qui j'ai affaire
les mecs du showbiz
je pense pas que vous soyez impliqués
quelqu'un va vous faire porter le
chapeau à mon avis
cette source dont je vous avais parlé et
s'est fait enlever
[Applaudissements]